enrique casalino bonjour et merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france on viens de
l'entendre 1 selon une étude américaine
les enfants de moins de cinq ans
pourraient être extrêmement contagieux
quelle est votre position à ce sujet je
pense qu'il faut rester prudent une
hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps
c'est un article intéressant mais ce
n'est pas un article qui apporte une
information disruptive il n'a pas fait
la preuve d'une augmentation de la
contamination à partir des enfants de
deux patients il a simplement apporter
un élément scientifique quelque chose
qui vient alimenter éventuellement un
débat mais qui n'est certainement pas
une preuve ça veut dire simplement qu'il
ya un peu plus de virus au niveau de la
gorge des enfants ça ne veut pas dire
que ces enfants contamine plus que pour
contaminer il faut tous et il faut
cracher il faut produire des aérosols
avec du virus et ça soit n'a pas été
trouvée et quant bien même ceux-ci
étaient prouvées faut-il encore apporter
la preuve que réellement les enfants
contamine beaucoup plus ça n'a pas été
fait il ya des études qui vont plutôt
elle rencontre où les enfants se
contamine peu plus mais eux ils ne
contamine pas davantage des personnes
je sais que ses côtés compliqué à
écouter pour nos auditeurs
je crois que le message qui doit rester
c'est il faut être prudent
si vous êtes un papa maman si vous êtes
des grands-parents des grands oncles et
vous avez des petits enfants qui
viennent à la maison il faut faire
attention et les enfants comme les
adultes
il faut pas leur faire la bise il faut
garder une distance de sécurité
il faut rester dans une attitude qui
limite le nombre de contacts et il faut
en permanence faire attention à ne pas
s'exposer inutilement un risque de
contamination
vous l'avez évoqué un plusieurs études
sont en cours et se contredisent et des
travaux notamment mené en ile de france
en juin qui montrait d'ailleurs que les
plus jeunes étaient de tout petits elle
contaminateur pourquoi ces études
données se contredisent toujours autant
ça fait partie de des données
scientifiques en sciences il n'y a pas
une ride
des absolus une vérité unique eu
conscience où nous progressons pas à pas
et nous faisons des comment vous dire
l'addition des données pour pouvoir
mener à des conclusions scientifiques
ce n'est pas du tout surprenant que
lorsqu on prélève des enfants on puisse
potentiellement avoir un peu plus de
virus et jean vous rappelle que
lorsqu'on fait des desserts dans la
gorge 10 à 100 fois plus de virus sont
nés ce ne serait que un blog ou de log
supplémentaires ce ne sont pas les
quantités astronomiques de virus donc
nous devons rester toujours très bombée
ré analysé les données scientifiques
avec beaucoup de modestie et passer un
message qui est un message de prudence
et un message qui peut être reçue et
compris par une population qui n'est pas
scientifique dans le domaine de la
médecine
le message de prudence c'est fait
attention
faites attention avec des adultes fait
attention aussi avec les enfants
éviter les contacts inutile éviter de
serrer les mains éviter les embrassades
même si c'est difficile je le comprends
parfaitement pour un grand parent qui
voit ses enfants
mais il faut éviter et faire attention
parce que le risque permanent le risque
de pouvoir être au contact de quelqu'un
qui a un virus qui est asymptomatique
existe chez les enfants chez les jeunes
chez les adultes et donc nous devons en
permanence être raisonnable nous
protéger nous et protéger les autres
alors pour vous cela ses conclusions
sont exagérées on l'a bien compris outre
atlantique l'administration 30 poussins
pour la réouverture des écoles et des
garderies dans différents états les
médecins de chicago se sont donc
interrogé sur la propagation du virus au
vu des résultats de leur étude est ce
que cette publication peut remettre en
cause l'ouverture des crèches ou la
garde des petits enfants par leurs
grands parents par exemple
non je ne crois pas je pense que
aujourd'hui les données ne me semble pas
assez solide pour pouvoir remettre en
question une stratégie globale
je vous rappelle qu'à l'enfant qui va à
l'école ce n'est pas il ne va pas à
l'école pour
on vous dira pour quelque chose qui nous
semblaient tous leurs à oui il faut
qu'ils aillent à l'école non il va à
l'école parce que c'est l'intérêt de
l'enfant et ce qui doit primer c'est
l'intérieur supérieur de l'enfant
si l'enfant il va à l'école c'est parce
que c'est dans son intérêt
c'est dans son intérêt intellectuel
c'est dans son intérêt en tant de
sociabilisation
c'est dans son intérêt parce que l'école
est le principal outil d'intégration
sociale dans le pays
donc il est essentiel que les enfants
aillent à l'école et cette nouvelle
donne et ne remet absolument pas en
question le fait que les enfants
puissent aller à l'école et que les
enfants puissent voir leurs grands
parents et leurs familles tout en
respectant les règles d'isolement les
règles de distanciation sociale et s'il
ya un moment les enfants de rsp avec
leurs grands parents
ça veut dire que pendant quelques jours
ils ont entre 5 et 7
ces enfants valoir des contacts au
réduit avec leurs grands parents
et ce n'est qu'après une durée chsld ou
huit jours qu'ils peuvent commencer à
avoir des relations normales puisqu'ils
sont confinés entre guillemets avec ses
grands parents avec qui ils vont passer
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines donc
soyons raisonnables l'important c'est
que les enfants puissent aller à l'école
l'important c'est que les enfants
puissent être en contact éventuellement
avec leurs grands parents
cette étude ne met en question sa
simplement il faut rappeler aux grands
parents il faut rappeler aux parents
faut rappeler à toute la famille on doit
faire attention aux enfants comme on
fait attention aux adultes
ça sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
enrique casalino pour cet éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes chef des urgences
à l'hôpital bichat
ap hp